[موسيقى]
أجنبية
نعم أتيت إلى هنا مع أحمد باتو
وجئت إلى هنا مع أصدقائي للحصول على
الشاطئ والحصول عليه
وآمل أن أشتريه ولكن نعم حتى أتمكن من
اصطحابه إلى الأرجنتين والاحتفال به اليوم  ونعم ،
لكن بالنسبة إلى المرآة التي تضعها
[ __ ] على ميسي ، فهذا أمر تاريخي وكل
ذلك ،
لذلك أعتقد أن هذه الشجيرة
رائعة ، إنها رائعة وتاريخية
لجميع الأرجنتينيين
، أعرف ما الذي يعنيه ذلك بالنسبة
لك بالنسبة إلى  الشعب القطري ، وإنه
لشرف لنا أن تضع الوحش
على ميسي وأنت تتعرف عليه باعتباره
أسطورة ، حيث لم يبدأ التمرين الذي
كانوا يبحثون عنه مع
علم الأرجنتين ، ثم بعد المباراة النهائية ،
كان الجميع يسألون مثل أين يمكنني ذلك.  شراء
ما أريده وأريد
إعادته إلى المنزل ، اعتقدت أنني
أعتقد أن الكثير من المعجبين أتوا إلى هنا ،
أريد أن أجرب على الأقل ، أردت أن أجرب
ذلك رائعًا بالنسبة لنا مثل هذا ، إنه
مثل أفضل تذكار  يمكننا أن نأخذ من
كأس العالم وسنعيد  عضو في هذه
الرغبة إلى الأبد ، أنا سعيد جدًا لارتدائه
لأتمنى وهو كأس العالم المذهل
[موسيقى]
أجنبي